foreign
there's a lot of slick marketing out
there from the credit card companies and
a lot of ads as we uh watch YouTube
videos and so I saw this one
from Credit Karma so we wanted to play
it for you and get your live reaction
Ken oh this is very he's never seen this
never seen it let's roll this Credit
Karma all right here we go
what are you doing applying for a credit
card on Credit Karma they had this thing
called the karma guarantee it's sort of
like a card fairy
if you apply for a credit card that has
the karma guarantee and you don't get
approved the card Ferry will slip 50
bucks under your pillow is he coming
tonight nope
just got approved the card Fair will
just have to rummage around in someone
else's fridge
get approved or get 50 bucks on offers
with the karma guarantee ah how
heartwarming wow it's so precious we
have the little the little cute little
girl the little Angelic voice what did
you he did the creepy wizard man and so
the whole thing is like like you know
like someone's gonna come save you you
know and I love the idea that if you
don't if you don't get approved for one
of these credit card offers because that
would mean you're in such bad financial
shape even credit card companies are
going nope yeah then Credit Karma will
give you 50 bucks right put it under
your pillow yeah that's the thing that
was sickening and and I gotta tell you
the other thing that it does the thing
that really bothers me is they're
playing to kids kids are in the room
while Mom and Dad are watching TV and
what's really Insidious about this is
and I mean Insidious is that they're
they're normalizing credit and credit
cards to little kids who don't even have
the foggiest idea what it really means
that's what's really and I'm telling you
I I can see it right now that their ad
marketing agencies that do all this
stuff for these companies they're
sitting in there going okay we have a
couple things we want to accomplish here
right and and and and don't think for a
second that the credit karma executive
said Hey try to make it this and let's
kind of I mean they are pounding this
into very intentional it's very
intentional to create normalcy
remember folks marketing is all about
removing your objections to anything
right it's why like we're sitting there
watching sports the other night with my
boys watching football game commercials
come on
and first thing it's one of these
pharmaceutical companies same tactics
I have dry mouth sore neck and itchy
feet I'm going well I got two of the
three what's wrong with me you know two
out of three there's nothing wrong with
me but it's like that it's a normalizing
of activity and normalizing of symptoms
normalizing drugs normalizing debt I
gotta Tell You Folks
um these people are very talented well
I'll tell you it's that game and you are
in The Matrix and until you wake up
you're going to be susceptible for this
I got to tell you shame on that that
that is so ridiculous it drives me nuts
and here's how this works Ken because
Credit Karma is partnering with all
these credit card companies and so
they're offering up discover and
American Express and all these different
offerings and they get Kickbacks if you
sign up and so they must be making buku
bucks if they're just throwing out fifty
dollar bills for anyone that gets denied
not to mention the ad development and
the ad buy now let's just go to where we
are real time all right George let's go
to reality again in my hands right here
a CBS News art article here's where we
stand and why Credit Karma is thriving
the average credit card rate in the U.S
is now more than 22 percent it's the
highest since 2019 this is according to
Lending Tree data for people who carry a
balance the average rate is 18.4 percent
according to the Federal Reserve and so
with inflation you know tightening
people's everyday activities instead of
reducing expenses increasing
responsibility more discipline what do
people do well inflation's more than my
pay raise so I gotta use a credit card
you sound just like them Kim that was an
amazing impression well no that's
actually the inner character what was
that Disney movie that it was like a
thing that had all these little emotions
and they became like characters that's
what that that's what that emotion
itself thank you James on top of it
because he's got the littles at home he
knows uh but that's that same sniveling
victim type personality I think that's
what they sound like yeah is that inner
voice the headline of this article is
inflation slammed Americans are piling
on credit card debt it goes on to say
steering inflation is driving Americans
to make more purchases on their credit
cards leading them to amass more debt
that is becoming costlier as the FED
hikes interest rates all right so you
know what the number is George hit me
887
billion dollars in credit cards taking
my breath away again that's up 13 from a
year ago go
wow
well we hear about the student loan
crisis and the number you hear is 1.7
trillion which means we are halfway
there in credit card debt alone nearly 6
in 10 Americans who earn less than 50
000 a year carry a credit card balance
from month to month but can't everyone I
talk to says well I pay it off every
month Ken what's wrong with hanging on
to my credit card I'll pay it off that's
a very good question George you have no
margin
all right so you start looking at I was
looking at some data today uh I was
talking about I was reacting to a viral
Tick Tock video on the Ken Coleman show
and where a tick tocker went out there
and said look if you make 25 an hour or
less you ought to be terrified as if
life is over okay now I want people to
make more than 25 an hour in fact I
commit my entire professional life to
you can make way more than that here's
how I want you to make more however it
was so Doom and Gloom so I looked into
the numbers he had this spreadsheet
basically showing that a person who
makes 25 an hour can barely make ends
meet in today's America well
what's on the spreadsheet the bunch of
debt the car payments and he had four
hundred dollars as the average car
payment you and I both know it's
actually
667.7 cars it's 519 for used cars I
looked it up today and I also looked up
that the median income right now in
America
uh per week
um is is just over a thousand dollars a
week so what happens is you do have a
lot of people who are really squeezed
but they're squeezed not just from
income but they're really squeezed by
expenses because all of a sudden if you
take out that 500 600 700 car payment by
the way that's the average
we saw a tick tock recently I think
James showed it to us
where people were like gleefully
bragging on these tick tocks I have a
car payment of 1200 hours
they work for car dealerships and it's
like it's mind-numbing George well and
it goes back to this whole thing that
we've normalized all of this through
marketing it's all around you everyone
you know has has payments that's right
it's in every commercial well it starts
with this little girl hey Daddy I'm
gonna have a thousand dollar car payment
one day
and it's just Insanity it's like the
Pied Piper leading people off the cliff
I mean was what are we doing here well
this it does start with do you want more
voices George all of them you could do a
one-man show at this point on Broadway
all right so here's what this turns into
you mentioned it Ken but yes you can
make more income an income can be an
issue but we have villainized every
company for not paying us enough all the
while we're throwing thousands of
dollars a month to lenders we're not
doing a good job
the answer is not pay me more and I'm
off for you make it more the answer is
what are we doing with what we have yes
and the truth is when you look down you
go oh it's all going to lenders who are
building really big buildings and
sponsoring every stadium in North
America today isn't that the truth so
how about we leave our own legacy and
put our own names on some buildings and
get out of debt once and for all these
credit card companies are not your
friend debt is not a tool and the truth
is credit cards have become the
cigarette of the financial world
we all used to think it was cool and now
we know too much and here we are an 887
billion dollar billion dollars of credit
card debt going I don't understand how
we got here I thought the credit card
company's my friend I go on free
vacations Ken yeah I get my points yeah
I'm beating the system no no because
life happens
and you don't have an emergency fund and
you're not hitting your financial goals
and so what do we do we turn to the
credit cards to be our savior and then
they uh they transform Ken before our
eyes into a devil instead of the Angel
you know I gotta tell you you know for
all of the wokism and all of the people
outraged by the bad people of society
it's high time the American people the
average person whether you're
conservative Progressive liberal or
whatever wake up and go the actual bad
guys are the credit card companies it's
predatory lending is what it is